janet yellen is the first female chair
of the United States Federal Reserve the
most powerful central bank on the planet
she is a steadfast policy maker with a
thoughtful and careful approach she is
renowned for being calm and collected
under pressure and criticism this is a
brief history of Janet Yellen 1946
Yellen is born in Brooklyn New York her
father is a doctor her mother a
schoolteacher 1959 Yellen attends Fort
Hamilton High School in Bay Ridge
Brooklyn she collects rocks 1963 Yellen
graduates high school as valedictorian
in class scholar she attends Brown
University's then Women's College
Pembroke she plans to study philosophy
she later switches to economics 1967
Yellen graduates from Pembroke she moves
to Yale University for her PhD in
economics she studies under Nobel
laureate James Tobin who held the view
that government spending could alleviate
recession she's impressed by a sense of
social responsibility 1977 Yellen serves
as an economist with the Federal Reserve
Board of Governors he meets fellow
economist George Akerlof they marry the
next year and become lifelong
collaborators 1978 Yellen rejoins
academia coming a lecturer at the London
School of Economics and later University
of California Berkeley she receives two
excellence in teaching awards 1994 after
years of teaching Yellen takes leave
from UC Berkeley to serve on the Federal
Reserve Board of Governors under Alan
Greenspan she argues for more fed
transparency 1997 Yellen serves on the
White House Council of Economic Advisers
under President Clinton she helps the
President formulate his economic policy
2004 Yellen heads back to the Bay Area
this time to become president of the
Federal Reserve Bank of San Francisco
2005 Yellen feels uneasy about the US
housing market saying quote the housing
sector represents a risk to the US
Outlook 2008 after she calls for the Fed
to act preemptively to protect the
economy Yellen
among the first Fed officials to call
the recession 2010 Yellen becomes vice
chair of the Federal Reserve job
creation must be a high priority of
monetary policy she is an outspoken
advocate for using the powers of the Fed
to reduce unemployment 2014 Yellen
succeeds Ben Bernanke as chair of the
Federal Reserve
she keeps interest rates near zero to
continue supporting the economy she
inspires the NYU class of 2014
congratulations and good luck 2015 the
majority of the year Yellen holds on to
the feds easiest monetary policy F she
plans to gradually unwind the feds
measures as the economy improves even
with surprises in global events Yellen
is sure to continue her evidence-based
approach to policy and keep calm and
carry on